what's up good humans welcome to another
episode you guys requested this one a
lot thank you Yasmin Rubio we hope you
guys enjoy Texas it's abstinence
abstinence abstinence they told us in
the health class just not to have sex
it's hard I mean every guy's nightmare
is getting their girlfriend pregnant and
sometimes it comes true
[Music]
my first thought was like I'll get him
abortion I'll go to Planned Parenthood
in the end it just when it came down to
it I realized that I couldn't do that I
understand how other people need to make
that choice but yeah I did totally
consider it I really had to think about
the other women in my life that I've had
children for me the first thought that
came to my mind was my mom cuz she tried
so hard to have a baby and if I were to
have an abortion after that it's almost
like disrespecting all the work she put
in and I was like okay I'm gonna have
this baby and then really it came down
to am I going to adoption or am I gonna
be a mom I planned this pregnancy a lot
of people might think otherwise and just
be like she's just saying that because
she doesn't want people to think the
baby was an accident I can't choose for
other people you guys have your own
choice but there's so many ways you can
prevent a pregnancy you could have done
it beforehand instead of once the baby's
already in there and trying to kill off
a heartbeat because the baby has a
heartbeat on his fourth week and that's
usually when everybody finds out they're
pregnant I don't have a choice for other
people so I mean everybody has their own
choice but personally I'm against it
[Music]
the way it happened with me I mean I
grew up in like a really like Christian
household so like it was always taught
like abstinence and like my parents
didn't even know that like I was having
sex and I mean I was using like condoms
but obviously I was naive that that was
gonna like work in the long run which it
doesn't I mean I knew that there were
options out there but it was something
that was never like explained to me that
I could get this so that I won't get
pregnant I'm from Texas and in Texas its
abstinence abstinence abstinence they
told us in the health class just not to
have sex so I honestly didn't know
pregnancy was so common I thought like
it just happened sometimes way you had
sex sometimes he would get pregnant I
really do think that that should be very
mandatory in school starting in like
middle school yeah I totally agree I
live in the mountains and it's really
conservative up there the schools are
really small I look at like my
boyfriend's little sister she's gonna be
12 and some of the girls and her grade
are having sex and she's she's in sixth
grade it's the information they're
giving you in schools needs to adapt to
where we are now in society to where
it's in the right grades it's the
appropriate information they're talking
about things like the implant that are
somewhat new and they really need to
just kind of adapt it to where we are
now
yeah as teen moms we need to take our
kids and teach them everything they need
to know from a young age like I thought
my mom was gonna be mad at me
so we may be open so they don't like
they're not like scared to come talk to
us about something that's so normal
[Music]
I used to be like super outgoing in like
high school in my classes and stuff
being pregnant I was like a college
student like there's many times that I
feel more timid to speak because I feel
like people judge me more and I mean
maybe that's something I just have to
work on but like definitely like my
relationship with myself has changed a
lot I bet you can all relate like you
meet your baby for the first time and
it's like life just shifts like almost
the glasses of like naiveness and
childhood just kind of come off and you
see the world from like that point of
view like you just created a life I
cried immediately for my mom and how
badly I treated her as a teenager before
I had my daughter and I cried for my
sister how I treated them teachers all
of the things that we were given and I
was entitled to now after having a kid
it all changed that just changed my mind
change the hardest person to tell for me
when I got pregnant was my brother we're
twins right now he's getting ready to go
to prom he's a senior in high school and
he's doing all this stuff that I'm
missing out on I want to take it back
for anything but telling him was the
hardest because we've always been so
close we've always been the same age
we've always had the same friends now
that my daughter's here and she's four
months old you know he comes home from
work and he's like oh hey and he asked
me to like holder and stuff and it's
really great and I love it so
relationships do change for the better
also yeah I would say for sure like my
relationship with my mom has changed
like drastically before I even got
pregnant like we were close but like not
in the sense that we shared like
something like motherhood with each
other because I think that just changes
everything that we now see what our
parents went through and what our moms
went through and how they felt my
relationship I felt with my mom has like
been really good because of my pregnancy
I mean originally like she's
disappointed in me but like but then
she's just like excited to become
grandma and stuff
[Music]
with my husband he's kind of too
involved he's kind of like excluding me
yeah like I could barely grab my baby
when he's around he was planned but
before it all happened he was my fiancee
well I do come from a Hispanic family
and also the religion and you had to be
married before having intercourse and
having a kid so we kept the baby a
secret for three months also to make
sure he's stuck before we told everybody
and we found out I was pregnant on a
Wednesday and I got married that
Saturday yeah so he's really really
involved I just want to ask you would
you have gotten married if you weren't
pregnant would you have gotten married
that early I should say if you weren't
pretty we were plenty gay married the
month after okay we were still gonna get
married this young it's just he came a
little earlier when I was 14 I got
pregnant my boyfriend was 14 as well and
we had already broken up before I found
out I was pregnant so when I found out I
was pregnant his initial reaction was
just like freaking out
getting abortion even though you're
three months along and one of the first
things he did was say I'm harassing him
and blocked me
we got a paternity test he decided that
I was some type of to have to I
found out I was pregnant even though he
was the only person I had ever been with
and after the paternity test the court
introduced visitation she was 10 months
old she was sorry she was 10 months old
and she finally got to meet her dad and
the visitation kept up for a while but
recently he's been getting into fights
and I mean he hadn't seen her in a few
months and I don't know if I want him in
her life I don't think it's healthy for
her I'd rather do it alone than with him
at this point what you expect from a
boyfriend what do you expect from a
father are totally different things
totally totally different things and
especially since men mature way slower
than girl
yeah why don't you end the fact that we
carry them for nine months and we're up
late at night if whether we breastfeed
or bottle feeding or whatever we are
just so inclined to these little human
beings and for guys you really have to
be there to do that and sometimes they
don't want to be there or they can't be
there for that they want to melt the
teenage years especially since they are
still teenagers there's still kids and
they want to they want to go party they
want to live their lives so sometimes
it's hard I mean every guy's nightmare
is getting their girlfriend pregnant and
sometimes it comes true I feel like I
wouldn't encourage them not go up to the
team like you should get pregnant hey
you should get pregnant if that's their
choice that's their choice if they could
be prevented if they'd feel like they're
not ready then just don't because I miss
my sleep I think it's interesting to
talk to you because you planned it yeah
if someone came up to me I wouldn't say
yes or no I would just be like are you
ready and I would give them so many
scenarios of do you have a job are you
ready for it
are you mentally prepared for it
something like that's the funny part
it's like everyone always thinks about
the financials and they always think
about do you have a place in this and
I'm like I get it those are so
incredibly huge but like mentally every
parent that I've ever met it's like it's
hard being a parent at any age yeah so
let alone figuring yourself out and then
you're figuring out a little human being
as well I think there's a huge
difference between supporting teen moms
and supporting teens to become moms I
think there's a big difference between
that 100% I think people look at it and
they see like what I post on Instagram
and this stuff I you know the stuff I
post on Instagram the things that I post
on Facebook perfect version of it it's
not what being a mom is actually like
because it's you know it's cute little
pictures of my daughter in dresses stuff
like that and that's not what being a
mom is like
[Music]
it's no longer like I'm just doing this
for myself I mean I can't compare it to
you guys yeah I guess right oh my baby
yeah but like I mean it's as simple as
getting up and going to my class but I
have a whole new motivation to do
something as simple as that and strive
for my best so the hard times became
beautiful because at the end of every
long cry that I had before her I had her
and I had you know our future to dream
about I'm over here going through some
of the hardest things and just she gave
me a whole new perspective so no it
didn't get easier but she turned
everything bad and good better okay
[Music]
[Applause]
- I just love when we featuring very
very different types of people and
people that you would maybe never
interact with or even new to in your day
we want to highlight these stories
especially of these groups that are
stereotyped Imams are stereotyped but we
just wanted to combat that yeah tell us
in the comments what other episode you
want to see we want to humanize
everybody we're but the Everett I'll see
you guys next time live deeper
you